insecure it's good to see you thanks for
joining us I know you're a big Arsenal
fan like me um it's football coming home
I bet you watched last night didn't you
I did watch last night and I really hope
it's coming home although you know
having been an Arsenal fan and an
England fan for many many years I know
what it feels like to think it's coming
home and then it never quite does but
this squad I mean last night I thought
Bellingham was fantastic really good to
see Kane getting a goal they look as if
they've got something special and they
operate well as a team together so
um you know I really really hope they
can go all the way I have to say France
is going to be tough anybody who watched
a bit of the um France game will see him
Bape on absolutely phenomenal forms so
that is going to be a really really
tough test for us but this is a good
squad
um and playing really well you know
flashes of real Brilliance in pretty
well all the games they've played so far
so everything crossed as usual for
um football coming home although I have
to say just on this the lionesses were
brilliant this year we've been singing
football's coming home for I don't know
how many years the women's team just
which case we'll go get it and bring it
home so we've got a bit of catching up
to do
talk to me about a New Britain which is
what you're unveiling today up there in
Leeds politicians always promising
um to give power to the people what
makes your plan any different
well this is a absolutely compelling and
comprehensive plan and the question that
I asked Gordon and the team to address
was how do we get our economy going how
do we make sure that our politics works
again and I think I strongly feel and
this is what I've been asking all Gordon
to focus on that that requires us to
stop pretending that those in
Westminster and Whitehall know far
better than those with skin in the games
in the in the game in the communities in
which they live and so I want to make
sure that we push power away from
Westminster Whitehall the biggest
transfer of power and resource closer to
people on the ground and that's in
relation to transport infrastructure
skills education everything you need to
allow the economy to thrive because I
think the biggest failure of the last 12
economic failure underpins the cost of
living crisis and I don't think that
we're going to fix that if we don't
allow all parts of the United Kingdom to
contribute okay we only have a finite
amount of time give me one example of
why somebody in what difference what
you're saying would make to somebody in
Hull this morning
uh well if you take
um Hull there are businesses being
created in whole we need to drive that
forward let me give you some examples of
what I mean by this you go to Dundee
well done well I mean Harley is a place
I've been told many many times and it
does need that drive in Hull the example
would be if you look around the country
there are a Dundee for example video
games they've got as a central industry
in the Midlands you've got Ceramics
Bristol and bath you've got Creative
Media we need that in every place Hull
and the Northeast I would like to see
part of a drive towards Renewables
hydrogen off the Northeast Coast
um so you know that may be an example
for Hull 300 economic clusters is what
the report is suggesting so that there
is an economic cluster for every place
but whether it's in Hull or in Burnley
or in Blackpool or in Sterling or in
Sunderland or Southampton everywhere I
go the local ambition burden for
economic growth what they can do is huge
they just want a government that's
alongside them and on their side and
that's what we want to deliver will you
abolish the House of Lords and will it
be in your first term
yes we do want to abolish the house of
laws I don't think anybody can defend
the House of Lords it's one of the
recommendations as you know in today's
report what we're going to do after
today is now consult on those
recommendations test them and in
particular look at how can they be
implemented because what I want to do to
answer your question is to make sure
that the talking bit which is how do we
now implement this it carries on now but
by the time we get to the election we
can get to the delivery bit and
everything within the report is intended
to be deliverable and the discussion
we'll now have is how do we Implement
when do we Implement hasselord is
obviously important but the central
process this is it it well look uh as I
say there's now discussion about when
we're going to implement do you hope
it's when I ask for the report
yes I do because when I asked when I
asked Gordon Brown to set up the
commission and do this I said what I
want is recommendations that are capable
of being implemented in the first term
obviously that I'm not going to pretend
that there isn't going to be a
discussion about implementing because if
we're going to push this amount of power
away from Whitehall Westminster we do
need to talk to the businesses the
communities Etc to say exactly how is
this going to be implemented because
we're going to get one shot at fixing
our economy and fixing our politics and
I want to make sure we get it absolutely
right so I'm not pretending it won't be
this period of consultation about
implementation but do I want to get on
with this do I want the next Labor
government to be absolutely delivering
from day one no longer talking yes
that's absolutely my ambition Okay
ambulance drivers rmt members nurses
midwives teachers Royal Mail fbu are
balloting today you've been uh we see
every week when it comes to pmq is the
prime minister saying that your step by
step with the Union Barons how much can
these unions expect your support
well look
um I completely understand the pressures
on working people in each of the areas
that you've discussed or just listed
um you know I I think everybody watching
this will feel that they can't pay their
bills prices are going up they're in the
supermarket they're picking stuff up
putting it back down again so there's
massive pressure down on people and I'm
not surprised across the country that
many individuals are saying I need a pay
rise but do does that mean I want to see
strikes and disruption no it doesn't
what I want to see is two things a
government that gets off its hands and
resolves the issues that underpin these
strikes and I remember a surprise for
example when it comes to nurses issues
that the health secretary isn't getting
around the table to discuss and to
negotiate what's going on so that's the
first thing I want to see the second
thing is this is why we desperately need
a change of government we've got to fix
the underlying problem which is the cost
of living crisis which is driven by 12
years of failure on the economy we
haven't grown our economy sufficiently
in the last 12 years that's why I'm
putting this report out today because we
coming into government will inherit a
broken economics and a broken politics
and we've got to fix it fast on behalf
of everybody in this country okay but
your Lisa nandy says that we can't
afford as a country inflation busting
pay Rises so these unions might want 11
12 18 they're not going to get it are
they and if labor was in power you
wouldn't give it to them either
but look I think that the government
needs to get around the negotiating
table that will have to be compromised
on both sides I think everybody
understands that
um but we don't want um to see this
level of disruption if you take the
nurses strike for example under the last
Labor government you didn't have nurses
going on strike and you did have Fair
pay for nurses that's the fundamental
difference that a labor government would
bring
um
rmt Union has rejected over the weekend
an offer from train operators for pay
increases of up to eight percent over
two years uh what more would you offer
them
well I'm not going to do negotiations
live on air I do think the government
needs to get around for specifics I
wonder how you will get at the rmt to
stop going on strike yeah
yeah I think when you get around the
table and negotiate if you look at just
to give an example of what I mean by
that in Wales where you've got um a
labor government similar issues in
relation to these strikes have been
resolved because they've got people
around the table so I don't accept that
it's impossible for government to do
anything I don't accept that it's right
for the government to sit on its hands I
think the government is sitting this one
out I don't think they should be I think
you know with people with the cost of
living crisis going into Christmas all
sorts of disruption on the cards I think
most people will be saying I want a
government that's going to get off its
hands get round the table knock heads
together and try to resolve these issues
and that's what we've seen in Wales it
ought to happen here my message to the
government will be get on with it
yeah although um I did speak um to a
Welsh Minister last week and they said
that they were expecting strikes there
as well
well many of the issues in Wales have
been resolved that's that's a fact
obviously you know as each issue comes
up not well you know as they come up
they need to be resolved okay
um you know as I said let me just
imagine the time let me ask you this if
I may please leader of the opposition
your wife works in occupational health
for the NHS as we know we clap for
workers like her throughout the pandemic
but now staff are being blamed for
bringing covid into care homes by the
former Health secretary Matt Hancock and
the subsequent deaths of a lot of
elderly people what do you make of his
comments in his new book
I I think you've already seen the
response of many people in the NHS uh to
that which is
um they find what Matt Hancock has to
say on this deeply deeply insulting he
was the man that said you know he'd put
a protective ring around our Care Homes
he did nothing of the kind
um and for him now having just got out
of I'm a celebrity to start now
publishing his diaries with his version
of events when so many people on the
front line put in so much day in day out
and they're exhausted I think everybody
knows that it was a huge effort by the
NHS they've come out of that exhausted
there's now massive backlog of waiting
lists which were far too high before we
went into the pandemic and there aren't
enough staff and one of the things I'm
most
focused on for the next labor companies
we're going to fix that staff problem
and we're going to train double the
amount of medical staff to come into the
NHS the coverage coming and we're going
to get rid of the non-dom status which
allows wealthy people not to pay their
tax in this country and we're going to
use that to fund NHS staff because talk
to my wife or anyone in the NHS the one
of the underlying issues is we haven't
got enough staff we're exhausted but um
I wonder if I could bring you back and
ask you about whether you uh if you were
prime minister would support tagging
Asylum Seekers
well look I think there's a case for
tagging in particular um cases but I'll
tell you what I would do which I think
um is more likely to fix the problem and
it's two things one I'd put resource
into the National Crime agency so we
could bust the trafficking gangs
Upstream because these gangs are making
huge amounts of money
we have to break them but but just just
that that's the first thing I do the
second thing I would do is get the
Asylum claims processed because tagging
is something you do whilst the claim is
being processed but no no hear me out
because this is of all the people who
arrive by small boats in 2021 four
percent have had their claims processed
that is utter failure by the government
and
um you know deal with it Upstream tackle
those criminal gangs okay absolutely get
your claims sorted out because four out
of a hundred cases dealt with for 2021
arrivals just not good enough okay let's
let's set I'm going to let you go but
let's end on a lighter note should we I
saw Angela Rayna a deputy leader of
course showing a video of herself DJing
at the weekend her choice of song was
set you free uh by entrance what would
your song be
well look I I phoned Andrew actually
after I saw that video footage and said
we like yin and yang which is what she
always says and I said to her when I saw
that footage I I couldn't do that
um but she was absolutely brilliant I
thought and good honor
but yeah but what would your song be
come on it's easy football I'm giving it
to you
oh well football's coming home of course
already Edwin Collins orange juice song
but football's coming home would be the
great one for now
okay and for that one
secure it's good to talk to you thanks a
lot